weiss wir jetzt schon entweder machen
dass du gegen rochus entweder es wird so
gemacht oder wir kriegen ein
riesengroßes problem meine sekretärin
herzlich willkommen zur ersten folge
einer neuen serie auf einem kanal ich
habe heute max an der seite und wir
dürfen heute zusammen die erste folge
von atv cbg atv c steht für hdtv
classics was für diese formate leute ist
ganz einfach denn es gibt so eine
gewisse handvoll videos auf youtube die
einfach jeder gesehen hat wo sie sprüche
herkommen die wir in unserem alltag
immer wieder verwenden
und genau diese absoluten legenden
videos des etv werden wir in diesem
format zusammen region für euch das
ganze besuchen leute wir schauen uns die
folgen reagieren darauf und am ende
bewerten wir die folgen nach vier
vorgegebenen kriterien das erste
kriterium ist der spaßfaktor also wie
lustig ist es das video anzuschauen das
zweite video ist der spruch faktor also
wie viele sprüche die man im alltag
verwendet sind aus diesem video gekommen
für den dritten faktor nämlich den mgz
faktor also den menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend faktor das ist quasi
wie sehr man sich fremd schämen wenn man
die folge schaut und der letzte faktor
ist die absolut wichtigste kategorie der
legenden status wie legendär ist das
jeweilige video aus itv und das ist auch
die perfekte überleitung unserer
heutigen folge denn heute schauen wir
uns den absoluten an
psycho andreas jahn schon leute dieses
video wird vermutlich bei legendenstatus
einen sehr hohen wert bekommen aber ich
will sagen wir schauen erst mal rein
hallo hallo andreas meine songs die ich
dann aus geht es dann in der kirche
machst du was du abendbrot was passiert
die aufnahmen aus dahin schon dieser
anfang findet alljährlich immer dieses
jetzt schaut man schämt sich für das
kind also hat mitleid mit ja und das
kümmern wie es auch so zach war
du bist nicht meine ich das was man über
dieser mann ist einfach eine legende
niemand kann sagen dass andreas keine
legende ist der typ hat einfach
deutschland geprägt wir müssen auch kurz
einfach mal über die einrichtung von der
wohnung
bei aldi ist meiner meinung nach auch
geisteskrank stabil
sie haben grüne wende die symbolisieren
hoffnung grünes auf die farbe der
hoffnung des erlebens von gras auch dann
haben wir ein sofa wahrscheinlich kann
rolf benz ist wahrscheinlich also blaue
decke susanne decke ist leider kein
fliesen tisch müssen klatschte aber
irgendwas sagt mir dass die auch obst im
haus ist und man schaut das habe ich
ganz vergessen und mein gott wie die
sprüche in dieser folge müssen den
wahlscheinen dort mein erster eindruck
als diese erste mal gesehen habe
hochnäsige ca junge dieses heute das
geht mir runter wie milch mit honig
alters ist so das ist so geil das ist
einfach nur sprüche diese hoch lebe ich
mit noch ohne witz das haben wir auch
schon so oft benutzt einfach so also
keine ahnung dass das echt krass man
muss wirklich noch sagen die so internet
- einfach die sprache prägen ja aber
ganz kurz noch heute bevor wir weiter
machen ganz wichtig ist dass ihr unter
jedem video eure vorschläge für das
nächste video rein schreiben also welche
nasa-tv classic sollen wir als nächstes
region der kommentar mit den meisten
likes gewinnt und kommt in der nächsten
folge dran und das allerwichtigste ist
heute bleibt bis zum ende dran um die
bewertung am ende mit zu bekommen fällt
ja alles oder gibts jagen was ist jetzt
total dass ein track steifen nicht also
er hat schon ganz eigenartige look muss
man sein mund ist so groß wie seine nase
es sind glaube ich nicht normal oder
würde so sagen da fühlt ist mein also
mein mund doppelt zu bereiten die meinen
ich kann meine kinder zu machen wird war
für mich der blanke chaos mir sind die
tränen gekommen kapitel jetzt natürlich
unterbrechen das kinderzimmer hast du
auch mal die größe gesehen hast die
menge ein spielzeug eingesehen alle
so galt es geht runter wie aber auch
geil die frau die hilfe kommt in seine
wohnung verkündet sie mal ist nicht so
schön eingerichtet sind ganz so wohl
konnten starb jetzt reicht es nein nein
jetzt das kinderzimmer es ist so ein
geiler erneute wir haben gerade 44
sekunden in diesem video gesehen und es
hat sprüche gescheppert die reichen für
drei generationen in deutschland
bei uns ist hier gehe nicht sauber es
wird jeden tag gesagt es wird aber eine
woche gewünscht um mehr hygiene kann man
einer haushalten nicht habe geld mehr
habe ich nicht gesehen aber
wahrscheinlich hat niemand mehr aber das
gehört aber sie verstanden er redet
einfach über jede also da bist du ja die
bude ist ja toll es geht um jeden ich
hab kein obst honig habt keinen die
musikfunktion was habt ihr von
verantwortung sonst kriegt man kann auch
sagen lasst uns zu krass und das dritte
zu sein
das können sie auch niemals so gut
schauspielern also wenn du das geschafft
hat öffentlich nee da gibt's ja noch
einen folgen also danach und so wurde es
wirklich dann so aufgedunsen würde wie
sie streiten und dann wieder sich
versöhnen und so aber es ist auch ein
stabiler charakter
die idee ist eigentlich die normale
gleich so andreas die normalen dies auch
schon ziemlich ja aber jetzt trotzdem
nochmals seine ganzen fehler kommt von
thema gucken wat dann sagt ich bin sauer
weil es um unseren einkauf geht die
junge das ist der spruch sogar ich kenne
ich kann ich spreche allen doch
auswendig
ich bin so aufgeht weil sie sagt dass
sie kein obst am haus haben obwohl man
sieht es ist ob sie muss ich bin sauer
weil es um unseren einkauf geht weil wir
angeblich von ihr hat man sieht hier
fasste angesprochen hat kein obst nicht
im haus haben obwohl man sieht es ist
obst im aus jugend ist so geil da es ist
obst im haus ist denn diese formulierung
ist so heftigkeit ja dass das original
so eine formulierung von jemanden der so
unter angela merkels bilder kommentierte
sie haben das diplomatisch vereinbarte
durchsetzungs gesetz nach § 14 nicht
vorsätzlich verbrochen dass du die
ausdrucksweise von jemandem der so
gerade aus dem zehnten stock auf den
kopf gefallen
und danach versucht schlau zu hören und
jetzt diskutieren wir weiter mit
dreijährigem aus dem kalender so eine
halbnackte frau immer drauf ist okay das
ist wirklich so asozialität so in
reinform
ich finde es aber gut dass er sich für
eine gepflegte diskussionskultur
einsätze also wenn wir es wird jetzt das
gut ich habe getrunken beruhigt habe ich
mich jetzt nicht das beruhigt auf einen
kaffee getrunken habe ich mich jetzt
nicht weil es jetzt weiter diskutiert
ich hab mal probeweise an der küste über
guckt da eine anspielung mit obst ich
hab mal in der küche gekuckt waren das
komplette skelett natürlich hat er sie
noch nie gesehen gibt immer auch durch
und dessen gemahlin design tastatur am
computer das sind 1 kalender oder hey
leute bitte sagt mir dass wir alle das
kennt es ist so legendär alter ja
dankbar
entweder bist du blind auf beiden augen
oder nur einfach blöd von mir kannst du
mal ein bisschen sachlich bleiben
warum das ist max oder die stimme wird
so laut ist nicht möglich sein so wie
man aus rot und so jemand auszunutzen
dann sieht man richtig so ist mein
haushalt yamaha es ist mein haushalt wir
führen ihn so für mich ist der menschen
in europa psychopathen drehen
psycho das ist das bedeutet dass wir
keine ahnung ich kann nichts mehr zu
sagen ich weiß nicht was ein psychologe
kann mit kritik überhaupt nicht umgehen
kann man trotzdem profine dass ich den
morgen mehr debatten bisschen zurecht
macht dass ich mich darauf wohl fühlt
dann würde ich ab morgen geschlafen
wir müssen was den jungen in den kopf
das bleibt alles so wie hier ist und es
wird sich hier nichts dran heute egal ob
du hier wird und nicht weiter hat der
wagen nicht so gemacht das hat mich so
wie ich bin ist doch
es ist so geil alter das aber so legende
ganz ehrlich das sollten kinder in der
schule lernen scheiß mal auf wilhelm
tell ding aber es ist es mit sprach ceo
andreas deutsches kulturgut wir auch
zurückgekommen
er sagt das so initiiert und respekt so
respekt einfach die wohnung sowie west
und es gibt sie ein nichts ändern
das können sie mal bleibt außer wie wird
sie hat ein bisschen ändern
es wirkt so als würde so eine anleitung
folgen die man sich aufregen kann ja
auch sein dass das skript ist also kein
recht sein es war ein kleiner kater
bevor es richtig ausgewertet
also möglicherweise haben die bei etwa
einfach gesagt so jetzt schreiben würde
mich nicht wundern also tut mir damit
solche taten kann ich kein kind
frauentausch macht von der hochnäsigen
zicke lasse ich mir überhaupt nicht
reinreden gruseliger gut so bleibt auf
dem pfad das bringt natürlich dass wir
auf dem richtigen weg die kann von
morgens bis abends irgendwas predigen
ich habe mein standard beziehungsweise
unsere familie hat ein standard danach
leben wir und es wird sich hier im
haushalt nichts verändern ja andreas n
standard
ein bisschen scheiße tür abschließen und
dann war doch für moment erstmal ein
bisschen beruhigt haben wir jetzt so
gedacht ich hätte heute erst mal so ein
bisschen mit angucken will ich bei euch
so lang damit erst mal ein bild machen
kann gefällt mir irgendwas spreche ich
drauf an der so wichtig also wenn so
eine verrückte zeiten rauskommt dass wir
klare kante zeigt sich magath für das
gefällt mir so ein fast von gestern
und wenn du meinst hast du jetzt wieder
möglich werden muss und muss jetzt laut
während werde ich nicht akzeptieren
dann werde ich die wohnung verlassen das
lasse ich nicht mit mir machen
das lässt sich ja auch nicht bieten hat
auch recht es ist mein haushalt wir
machen den so und es wird sich hier
nichts zu rütteln
egal was du hier bist und nicht und ich
lasse mich als psychopathen bezeichnen
nach dem spruch gestern der sicherung
psychopathische steht mit grundsätzlich
also kann ich hoffe dass er noch mal gar
nicht ist völlig normal und schreien ja
in welcher form sieht man schreien an
bei uns ist der laute ton gang und gäbe
ja in welcher form sich hin sprach ihn
an
durch den menschen wird ja in welcher
form ich werde dir die aufgaben geben
die auch meine frau übernommen hat alles
weil so sehr sagt die toilette ist
unhygienisch und hat geb ich das zeug
aber ich erkläre die auch die reiniger
was für was es um wie gefährlich die
sind irgendwie diesen zettel nur unter
männliche aufsicht verwenden und davon
im haus von andreas nur unter männliche
aufsicht aber finde ich cool von ihm
dass er auch die reiniger zeigt und wie
gefährlich die sind so und jetzt sag ich
dir einige täter überhaupt nicht in hand
nimmst das ist meine aufgabe bei diesen
zu gefährlich für das ist einfach so
hofreiter
dass die die filme können hier überhaupt
kennt er sich jetzt schon drehen
die kameramänner so in gefahr wegen
ihrer linie von den reinigern aber
gucken was die die am ende
wahrscheinlich
das sind bereit die gerade gar cillit
bang oder links ist das nicht so ein
allzweckreiniger davon hintergrund weiß
was jetzt kommt entweder machen es nur
wurde wir haben
entweder es wird so gemacht oder wir
kriegen ein riesengroßes problem sei
also das ist ja sowas von lächerlich so
was von lächerlich besser du machst dich
hier voll zum obst der woche soweit
benutzt die verrückt hallo nur unter
männliche aufsicht bist du krank bist
sind ja auch chemikalien die besonders
weibliche haut an seien männlich als das
hat ganz anders aufgebaut als zweites
leben aber die sache ist ja der macht
das ja nicht weil er bösartig ist
sondern die wälder schützen und ich lebe
noch immer noch nicht gestorben und dass
sie keine ansprüche an und wird steht
groß und breit druck macht man für den
fußboden fußrücken weniger als zu
gefährlich im fall von denen ihr
anschreiben ich hab da was machst du mit
mir nicht und ich hab ja häufig voll
vergisst man das ja früher da gibt es
auch keine wörter mal zu verstehen ist
und der ritter sie zu der ja
wahrscheinlich auch im schnitt gesetzt
werden die behinderten kann irgendwas
bestätigt
das ist aber kein holz mehr sowie der
dämon durchkommt das war so ein psycho
andreas wie wir ihn kennen kommen wir
jetzt zur bewertung spaßfaktor was gibst
du viel spaß irgendwann das schaut also
wir müssen aufpassen die höchste
bewertung zu geben natürlich jetzt
direkt bei der ersten folge
ich würde aber sagen spaßfaktor ist
schon 98 oder 19
ich finde es eine gute neuen weil das
sind so viele
man erkennt so lustig das ist ein echter
ansprüche berater wie ich bin ich kurz
davor eine 10 zugeben ja aber ich will
auch wieder einen neuen geben weil es
muss eigentlich immer luft nach oben
soll ja sagen wir neuen ok auch noch ok
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
faktor wie abstoßend findet man was aber
schaut ich weiß ja weil ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht 00 aber ich darf man muss sich
so rein versetzen den ersten moment wo
man das geschah da denkt man sich so oh
mein gott das war halt eigentlich auch
ziemlich viel aber ich würde sagen
dadurch dass man sich mittlerweile schon
so daran gewöhnt hat kann man eigentlich
nicht mehr als 0 7 gehen ja welche aus
27 jetzt kommen wir abschließend zur
wichtigsten kategorie legendenstatus ich
glaube dass zehn von zehn gibt es wenig
was so ikonisch ist und 15 millionen
klicks leute 15 millionen mit einem
upload zehn von zehn legendenstatus das
war die erste folge von also tv classics
heute kommentiert jetzt mit dem nächsten
video das wir in dieser serie anschauen
sollen max ist in der beschreibung
verlinkt abonniert diesen kanal viel
mehr solcher videos und checkt hier
drüben mag sich die richter dafür
einfach ich vorgeschlagen das video ab
wie nach fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten